good to see you man how are you
good to see you i'm doing very well
thank you how are you
i'm doing great listen i don't know how
much you believe in manifestation
but i was wondering if this photo
that you posted of yourself
your head next to a giant spider
everything to do with you manifesting
this role in spider head or this film in
general
well
now that you bring it up i mean possibly
yeah yeah
unintentionally on a sort of
subconscious level i guess i
i sent that message to the universe and
to instagram and then here we are
yeah yeah joe saw that he was like this
is the one
and he had several other people in mind
and then he saw that photo and said wait
a second
this is the guy
um i have to say it's always a lot of
fun watching you have fun on screen as
your characters but how
how can steve be so light-hearted about
doing work that is arguably very dark
yeah that's what um i found fascinating
about the character and about the script
was
you had this individual who was
charismatic successful
very powerful highly intelligent driven
self-motivated
it'd been a huge huge ego that didn't
really allow for
the you know any any empathy really or
the the social a big lacking of social
etiquette and social cues and um you
know as much as he understood the
science around you know behavioral
science and individuals
he was kind of void of a lot of the
emotions that were needed to uh to be a
decent human being um
you know and so coupled with a very dark
twisted sort of sense of humor at times
as well made for made for a wild
character a lot of fun
were there parts where you kind of
surprised yourself into in the places
that you went here
yeah the hope was to surprise myself you
know i wanted to
not know exactly where i was going to go
with it you know i had a lot of
different ideas and different influences
buried inside
my my body and my head um
built up my instincts around sort of my
opinions on this and who this character
was
and then
it was just kind of go for it you know
we had a space it was very controlled
environment where we shot it was much
like a
theatrical a theater piece you know like
being on stage um the way joe shot it as
well and allowed us the freedom to move
within these spaces and and do whatever
we wanted and um
yeah and then it's sort of
you know when i saw the film i was i was
really proud of what we'd created and
the fact that it was something that i do
believe is very unexpected and and fresh
uh finally miles seems to be pretty fat
pretty proud of the fact that he uh beat
up thor uh in this movie care to comment
um he should be proud you know um
but well did he beat up thor
we had a scuffle maybe without giving
too much away but you'll have to see the
movie to decide who who's the reigning
champ
in that instance
fair enough i was without my hammer and
cape though so you got me on a bad day
yeah at a disadvantage all right man
so good to see you as always congrats on
the film thanks a lot